مدرب كره قدم اسبانيا كبير درب كبر الفرق
في اوروبا برشلونه بايرن ميونخ العام
بيدرب مانشستر سيتي اللي حقق معه تسعه
القاب كبيره منها الدوري الانجليزي لكن
كمان دوري ابطال او خلينا نقول انه لكن
دوري ابطال اوروبا تحديدا لسه مستعصي عليه
معهم غوارديولا هذا اللقب مع برشلونه فقط
مانشستر سيتي اصلا في حياتهم ما اخذوا
اللقب هذا لا مع غوارديولا ولا مع غيره
طبيعي انه يصير ينسال كثير غوارديولا عن
هذا اللقب اول امس كان في مباراه لمانشستر
سيتي كسبها سبعه صفر وكان الجوارديول
لمؤتمر صحفي بعد المباراه وفي فاجا الناس
فالمدرب يعني
مثل ما بيقولوا بالانجليزي الكثير ناس في
عالم كره القدم والتدريبه لكن في المؤتمر
هذا
عن حبه وتقديره للي بيعتبرهم هو
بصراحه فجاه كتير ناس
الشديده انها يوم ما زالت او ما زالت
بريطانيا راحت زارت مانشستر يونايتد جاتهم
الرجال والخليل نقول الجورديولا يعني
بحبها لدرجه معتبر انه لو ايش ما عمل شايف
نفسه فاشل لانه يوم ما زارت بريطانيا ما
جاءت لي مانشستر سيتي اللافت اكثر في
الموضوع انه الزياره اللي بيتكلم عنها
غوارديولا كانت في 2016 ومانشستر يونايتد
بعد تصريح مدرب الفريق المنافس قرر يعمق
جراحه اكثر وقام ناشر على حساباته وصور من
زياره جوليو روبرس للنادي وعنوان هابي
تروباك
تصريح بورديولا هذا عن حبه لجولي روبرت في
اعتبارهم نفسه فاشل ايش ما حقك في حياته
لان ما جت زارتهم كثار ناس شافوه تعليق
دمه خفيف وحتى تفهموا احساسه يعني وحسوا
انه لو مكانه يعني حيكونوا عندهم نفس
الشعور يعني
لكن في كثير ناس وتحديدا من معجبين النادي
مان سيتي غضبه من مدرب فريقهم وما عجبهم
كلامه وشافوا انه في اهانه وتقليل من
النادي وما يجوز كده
طيب
الموضوع مو بس عمل ازمه لكن كمان تحول
لموضوع اسئله لناس تانيه لها اي علاقه في
الموضوع فمدرب ارسنال مثلا لقي نفسه في
مؤتمر صحفي بنسال مين الايدولز حقهونك
اللي نفسك انهم يجوا يزوروا النادي
[موسيقى]